as [ __ ] ass has bad words hmm hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast we discuss what it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 134 today
we're gonna talk about being intentional
we're talk about living deliberately
we're gonna talk about intentionality
and Ryan if this were a regular podcast
right here is where the first
advertisement would go the very
unintentional advertisement well it'd be
an intentional placement of the
advertisement yes interesting let's save
that that's good cuz there's a question
later during the lightning round where
we talk about like setting intentions
versus intentionality right and and some
of the differences there is hopefully
we'll be able to talk about that but
since this isn't a normal podcast
actually this is a pretty normal pod I
mean for you and I it's normal yeah yeah
I mean we're we're we're if you could
describe listen to words it'd be
aggressively normal okay and no I mean
but if since we're not gonna talk about
any advertisers or whatever anything
I've got some follow-up before we dive
into these questions so last episode
you'll remember was about constraints
yes and we were having some
conversations there and there was one
thing that I forgot to Mitch I was
talking about vexes and my
unconventional relationship and some of
the constraints around that and I didn't
bring it up when we were having the
conversation because I thought that sort
of went without saying but the more I
thought about it after recording that we
have some constraints where she lives
part of the time elsewhere half the time
else where I live half the time with her
and so we have these constraints in our
life that we have to navigate around
right mhm and the thing that I meant to
say last time is that constrain actually
makes our life better it was not it
wasn't it it wasn't an intentional
constraint at first we just knew that
like it was a necessity right my life is
like your life comes with certain
constraints yes in order for you and Bex
to have a relationship there are certain
constraints that that are there right
you you are you have to deal with right
yeah and
so the the analogy that I was thinking
about is the water is constrained when
it comes to your house right it you
don't tell within pipes exactly the
pipes can strain water doesn't come out
until you turn the faucet on I don't
know where you're going with this but
yes I agree the pipes are are a perfect
analogy here because that is a type of
constraint you're constraining the water
I can't just seep into the ground the
pipes are going underground you can
strain the water within the pipe so that
it can get where it needs to go and and
and the thing that we were talking about
that there really stood out to me and
something I've been thinking about a lot
since we recorded that last episode is a
lot of these constraints actually
increase our freedom in the long run but
by saying no temporarily by temporarily
constraining ourselves or adding these
limitations
I feel like quite often our life is
better as a result it increases our
freedom and so if you haven't listened
to that episode I would definitely
encourage you to to go back to that one
thing that I talked about recently I
wanted to just follow up with you on
Ryan is that TV series documentary
series rather called wild wild country
oh my god the the sort of cult I see
Sean sort of shaking is that apparently
he did someone on that documentary man
well it was a great documentary I'm just
torn how I feel about it
yeah it was it was so well edited if I
were to have any criticism about it it
seemed like almost pro cult in a way yes
yeah that's that yeah and and there are
things that although they clearly they
presented some of the terrible stuff
that cult did but the vast vast majority
of the people there were actually when
does a cult become a religion yeah I
don't have 200 years yeah I don't know
the timer is it people it's probably
it's probably a little bit of both I
don't know and and then the question is
like and I don't think it's either maybe
maybe it's actually perspective because
I hear you know you we have two friends
Rob Bell and Sam Harris Rob Bell would
call Christianity or Catholicism of
religion Sam Harris would call
Catholicism the
the religion I grew up in a cult and of
course Scientology most people would
call Scientology a call so it wouldn't
wouldn't call in religion it I mean
they're kind of synonymous right well
maybe although you saw in the
documentary what the guy Osho was trying
to do is he was trying to abolish the
the religion and ribald he didn't want
it to be a call he didn't it at least
that's what he said and and obviously we
can we could argue about that and it's a
I think it's a solid documentary series
it's well worth the time invested and
it's some of the absolutely the six
episodes about fifty minutes each so
some of the best editing I've ever seen
there was this a few years ago Ryan we
had someone reach out to us they bought
this huge building in South Dakota yeah
it was this government building that had
been built with the the 2009 or early
Barack Obama administration the the
government funds the the shovel right it
was one of the shovel ready projects
that was built in the middle of South
Dakota had this huge industrial kitchen
and like 30 different rooms it was this
conference center that was built in
Howard South Dakota yeah and the person
who purchased it reached out to us that
he wanted to turn into a minimalist
compound basically yeah I mean basically
he asked us to go to this this retreat
and run it where it would be you know
the two of us and then there are how
many they had like 20-something rooms
there yeah close to 30 so yeah so it
looks 1230 rooms so then you've got
you've got you and I there so that
leaves 28 rooms the idea was for us to
bring people out to help them cultivate
passions help them to work on their
projects that they don't have time to do
like basically we were supposed to give
them the resources of time yeah and of
housing to basically guide them into not
being minimalists but more or less I
don't know what help me out here just
changing changing their direction in
life and I think the
vision and the things we talked about
we're having sort of long-term
residency's short-term residency's and
then really short like like one week to
one month stays as well so you could
have long-term residents there you could
have on-site yoga I never had like it
really like strict plan around this no
we were just kind of briefly talking
about it to me it sounded cool though to
be like hey you are you're someone who
you know has not been given an
opportunity to really live a meaningful
life whether it's someone's born in the
wrong neighborhood or someone just
doesn't have supportive people around
them in general right or someone just
doesn't have they don't have the time
they don't have the resources to work on
that on that you know passion project
that they have like I thought it was
really a cool idea in that sense of
bringing people into to help them change
their lives for the better
yeah but but you're right there wasn't a
fully fleshed out plan but there was a
lot of planning that went into it yeah
so the guy who owned it got it in a
relatively you know basement price and
bargain basement price and he flew out
to meet with us and and we talked about
it we considered it we threw out some
ideas and and we were and we were
considering even going out there and
touring it and and going through the
whole process eventually we decided to
say no because it was this is 2014 so
four years ago and we were getting
better at saying no to a lot of things
at the time and this was one of the
first big opportunities where we had to
say no to it because it would have been
dedicated next year maybe several years
to to forming this sort of minimalist
compound and now that I look back on it
you brought this up after watching wild
wall country you're like I'm so glad we
didn't do the South Dakota thing but not
because I you not because some people
wouldn't have gotten value from
certainly some people would have gotten
value from it but you and I are out
proselytized we're not trying to convert
anyone to minimalism and we sure as hell
don't want to be a couple of cult
leaders and and sometimes I think these
things can accidentally turn into that
and so I think that was the perfect man
to kick off today's episode when we're
talking about intention
ality for us like it's in we
intentionally want to avoid being some
sort of cult leaders you know the only
followers we want our followers on
social media kind of thing yeah it's so
funny dude I think we could probably
have an hour-long conversation just
about wild wild country man yeah and
like how everything transpired because I
do look at the South Dakota thing and
I'm so glad we didn't do it because of
the perception behind it honestly like I
know that you and I are not out to be
called leaders but the perception of hey
you know we've got a community that you
can come to I mean there's just a
certain stigma that goes with it I mean
I remember when we were in the UK I was
talking about the minimalist org
communities and I had worded it in a way
you remember this we're in Leeds and I
was like I said something like yes Josh
and I we want to UM we want to tell you
guys about the communities that we're
building and like their eyes got so big
and I didn't even catch it I just
continued to talk and you cut me off
you're like whoa let's be very clear
about what these communities are but I
mean my point is is like just me wording
minimalist or wrong yeah would you just
meetup groups right exactly like me
boarding that wrong has a certain stigma
with it has a certain perception that
comes along with it yes we have to be
very careful with the very precise and
the language we use and and it's not to
say that we won't ever do conferences or
events or anything like that but it's
being intentional about what we're
bringing to the table and and I think
the important thing is whether it's a
call or whatever else the things that
that that really get people in the
trouble is ideology or dogma especially
dog-bone right and so that's the thing
that we want to avoid I'm always willing
to to change my mind but I also real
realize there aren't any Universal sort
of rules of minimalism that work for
everyone yeah you know I think what we
do is we help people who have Dogma or
who don't have Dogma right but we are
very neutral when it comes to those
types of beliefs but I think the cool
thing about what we do in the in the
ideas and the topics we talk about like
it transcends all cults religions
atheists that's what you'll see when you
come to our events like it's all
different types of people showing up
so I what I'm trying to say is like
minimalism to me is this
it's an enhancer or maybe it's not an
enhancer but a compliment
yeah to someone's life whether whether
they're religious or not yeah that's
that's exactly it and you find the the
the number one commonality is that it's
people with an open mind people who are
dissatisfied with whatever the status
quo is regardless of religion or race or
age or background socioeconomic status
you come to one of our events and you
certainly see that speaking of events we
haven't announced this yet so that
you're the first one to hear about this
we're going on another tour oh my god
you told me we were never gonna tour
again judge alright so I think I think
we figured out this time we're going on
a really big small tour what are we
doing this time Josh it's three cities
three states okay three days well it's
not over three days it's you know we
like skipping different events yeah
three different events we're going it's
called the simply southern tour and it
is Kentucky and Tennessee and Alabama
now what by the time this comes out
tickets will not be on sale yeah they do
not go on sale to the general public
until June 8th 2018 but if you're a
patreon supporter you'll get access to
the best seats in the House you get
access to the presale tickets on June
the 6th now we're gonna have this is
gonna be different from any past tour
style this is not this isn't the less is
now tour yeah we're not we're not given
that that same talk where I talk we're
not given to talk at all we're bringing
special guests now we can't announce
those guests yet because we're still
working out details with their publicist
but think about where these are going to
be it's going to be in the south it's
going to be in Tennessee and Kentucky
and Alabama so what kind of guests might
we have here's here's a hint we're gonna
be talking a little bit about money on
this tour and so think about that maybe
we're gonna talk about kids maybe we'll
talk about retirement we're gonna talk
about your finances and budgeting on
this three-city tour so details come in
over at the minimalists comm if you're
interested in that or if your patreon
supporter you'll have first access oh
one last thing before we get into the
questions Ryan thanks to everyone who
showed up I did a home tour on Instagram
this month earlier this month and over
8,000 people showed up on Instagram live
nice which is really cool and the video
was supposed to stay posted for 24 hours
and then disappear now it did stay post
for 24 hours but apparently it froze at
the 22 minute mark so if you attend the
live thing you got to see the full hour
and I answered a bunch of questions and
we had a really good time but if you
watched it afterward it got stuck after
you had basically my dining room so that
it is a bummer but the good news is I'm
going to do a second filming of that not
a livestream but I'm going to record a
video in early June for our YouTube
channel so if you want to take a proper
tour of my home mine and Becks is in
Ella's home then you can do that over on
YouTube early June just head on over to
youtube.com slash the minimalists or if
you're a subscriber to our email list
over at the minimalists comm then it
will show up right your emails phones as
well I'm feeling this pressure to do a
video tour of my home but it's not
nearly as nice or interesting as your
home interesting there's nothing there's
nothing interesting about my place like
it looks like it's a normal place like
there's nothing people would walk in
there and they would be like this is a
normal place aggressively normal
pressive ly normal house tour yeah we
got to do it now we're branching out to
more video stuff more on that later in
the podcast we're going to talk about
some other video stuff that's this
coming really soon we've got some
questions want to answer about
intentionality our first question is
from Emily in Baton Rouge Baton Rouge I
say that right do you think that
everyone is supposed to leave their
corporate jobs because we hear a lot
about you guys leaving your clover job
and everyone wants to leave their
corporate job to do this or blog or
whatever actually run my own blog so I
don't want to go too into corporate at
all but I'm just wondering if you think
that everyone should not work a
corporate job what do you think Josh
should everyone leave their corporate
jobs right now
yeah and start a blog but if you're has
the blogs if you get the gals already
are you there you've got the solution
there yeah so it do I think everyone is
supposed to leave no I mean I I had to
go buy us USB cable recently and so I
had to go to a corporation to do that
and so people and you know they offered
me that I was buying a you'l one USB
cable mm-hmm and at checkout they
offered me 18 months financing they
offered you financing on a USB cable on
a USB cable that's like offering that's
almost like offering a warranty on a USB
cable like like he offered that to well
you know what did court here's the thing
about corporations man corporations are
not like they're not inherently bad and
what I mean by that is there are some
really good corporations out there
especially B corporations now there's
only what twelve hundred V corporations
in the United States but a B corporation
is they have to meet certain
requirements it's it's more similar to a
non-profit and profit is no longer the
primary objective of a corporation but
even if you're a large corporation or S
Corp you're right it's not inherently
bad yeah the problem is when
corporations they they put money first
over everything else and unfortunately
that is that is the situation we're in
right now what causes that I mean I
would say it's crony capitalism that
causes that but but regardless that's
the state we're in right now so when a
corporation makes money the bottom
dollar when it is their number one
driver that means people come second
that means environment comes second but
what comes first is offering you 18th
month 18 month financing on a USB cable
I mean what would I do show up each
month and give them a quarter I have no
idea there's this cartoon I cut out I
didn't know with the word I could use it
today but this is perfect so this is a
cartoon from The New Yorker Ryan do you
see this it's to mob guys and they have
this college graduate who is in a bucket
of cement and they're getting ready to
push him off the dock just like God and
what is it I can't reaction once the
caption says it's not personable it's
not personal the boss just doesn't like
seeing people and so much debt for such
a useless degree and and I would say the
same thing about a USB cable if you have
to finance if you have to finance
anything with the exception of maybe a
mortgage then then the it's it's
probably a bad idea you know what's
probably a bad idea if I had a magic
wand to like just wave and say you know
what you know what a magic wand
basically to put in regulations to say
all right an 18 year old kid isn't
allowed to you know get into six figures
worth of debt as soon as they get out of
school corporations they're not allowed
to put money first had to put people
first an environment environment first I
wouldn't do it and I'll tell you why
well a I hit regulations yeah I think
some of them necessary but I think I
think buying by and large like it's it's
just not I'm not person on a fan of
government regulations but what we can
do though is what we're doing now I
think and that is talking about these
issues hopefully you know reaching the
hearts of some people to to make the
right decisions in hopes that they they
can kind of change their you know
priorities and I think here with a go go
ahead they can self-regulate is what
you're saying yeah yeah look is we cuz I
don't want to like we have all the
freedom in the world and like we have
the freedom dude if you and I wanted to
yeah our diet could consist of nothing
but Twinkies and Mountain Dew right like
we have that freedom but we have to be
responsible with that freedom and I
don't think regulations are what is
going to help people be more free yeah I
guess I don't know why I'm going off on
a regulation this segment is brought to
you by Mountain Dew but no I I think for
Emily here it's it's important to to
realize that she can't self-regulate
she doesn't want to be at the corporate
job that's okay why don't you want to be
at that corporate job does it not align
with your values and beliefs because if
it doesn't yes that's a problem but
there are certainly corporations out
there Emily that you can go work for and
they will align with your values and
beliefs if I had to go work for a
corporation like if someone you know put
a gun to my head I don't know I probably
just and pull the trigger but just out
of spite but no I but seriously they
don't have the
guts to pull that trigger but you know I
I just I just wouldn't have a problem
going and finding a corporation to work
for like I know there are some good ones
out there are you know I just start my
own and make it a good corporation yeah
and then maybe here's other thing if
you're working for a large corporation
maybe you're not gonna change the the
structure of the corporation but what
can you change what does in it what is
in your world and within your wheelhouse
that you know you can change and maybe
maybe that corporation is Starbucks you
work at a Starbucks you know certainly
not the best coffee and and depend on
what store you're in it could be great
culture and you're not gonna change the
entire company you're gonna change the
corporate offices up in Seattle at least
not not today but the one thing you're
in control of is how can I create an
outstanding customer experience for the
next person who walks in front of me and
and by doing that you start to change
the culture of not the entire company
but of your division now your division
happens to be that one little retail
store and there are thousands of other
Starbucks retail stores you're not
changing them but you're changing what's
in your world right now yeah or maybe
you're just like you don't you're not
even managing the Starbucks maybe just a
barista there
mm-hmm but it's like still asking that
question every single time how can I
create the most meaningful you know
customer experience like that that will
a it rubs off on the customers they
appreciate it but it also rubs off on
co-workers now the easy thing to do in
in most work environments especially
when they tend to be you know lean
towards the toxic side it's easy to just
go with the flow it's easy to be
negative it's easy to to sit there and
bash the company embed it and just go
along with all that right because you
you don't want to get bashed as well and
so you feel you figure like well the
only way that I can fit in here is if
I'm also negative but the only way to
change that to to reverse the downward
spiral is to to stop participating in
and you don't have to participate now
this means for Emily she might have to
where she is I can hear the sort of
despair in her voice and do I think
everyone should leave the corporate
world no but it sounds to me like you
should probably leave where you're at if
you feel that you are not empowered to
make some changes so hey the question is
can I change the situation on in
temporarily because the best time to
look for a
you job is when you already have a job
than what you're not desperate so try to
change the position that you're in but
then if you're going to leave let's have
a plan I think there are four things
that I want to do whenever I'm
identifying what a plan is I know Ryan
always talks about you make sure you
have a plan here the four things that I
look at say okay if I'm gonna have a
plan the first thing when I ask is what
does my outcome or what is the
destination where am I going to go right
and then second is where am i right now
what's my current location if I need to
know what my destination is if you pull
up your Google Maps or whatever it needs
to know where you're going but it also
needs to know where you are right now
right so take an inventory of where you
are right now you know where you are and
then where you're going and the next two
things the only other two ingredients
gonna change between where you want to
go and where you all right now as time
and actions right and so how long is it
gonna take for you to get there well it
depends what actions you take it's gonna
take me three days to get to New York if
I Drive there it's gonna take me what
2025 days if I walk there if I fly there
it's gonna take what five hours and so
what what are the actions I'm going to
take that's gonna reduce that amount of
time it's a great analogy and so those
four things outcome current location
time and action look at your calendar
too so so and if I look at your calendar
right now I can probably tell you what
your priorities are and if you don't
have a whole lot of stuff in your
calendar if then you probably don't have
a whole lot of priorities you don't know
what your priorities are
schedule the things that you want to
change the actions that you need to take
to change I think the one thing I would
add add to that is if you if you're
going through this plan you've got a
plan you're taking the actions and it's
not working you've got to change your
approach yes and I mean that's a total
ripoff from Tony Robbins but but it's
absolutely true because what I see and
it's a lot of lot of mentoring students
I talk to is they have a plan they're
working on and they feel like it's not
working and then I'll ask them like well
what have you done differently well I
haven't done anything differently it's
like well that's you got to change your
approach sometimes that's great yeah so
if if reevaluating and you look at and
you're like well it did I've been
driving for three days and I didn't end
up in New York I am in Toronto you're
like
okay well you need to cheat you you
needed to reevaluate before you got
Toronto but now you're there
Yuri evaluate now last thing I'll ask
you Emily is what do you want to create
what are you curious about because if
you can answer that question where you
get it's not just yeah we don't need the
grandiose statement as I have to follow
my passion or I need to live my life's
mission I think that's great if you can
identify what you're passionate about
beautiful
in fact if Ryan and I were going through
this exercise yesterday and in fact we
were doing a patreon livestream for our
patreon supporters and someone was
talking about identifying what they're
passionate about and I've found for me
one thing one way to identify that is if
I were to tell you you couldn't do
something for a year what is the thing
that would drive you insane if you
couldn't do it for you for me it's
writing for sure there are other things
as well and that's okay to have multiple
passions but if you were to say Josh for
the next 12 months you're not allowed to
write a single word oh my goodness like
that I would feel such despair from that
yeah and that that leads me to say okay
that's the thing I'm passionate about
but if you don't have something like
that then maybe ask yourself some some
easier questions what are you curious
about what do you want to create and
because if you if you're if you're
looking if you're concentrate on what
you want to create as opposed to I
here's this job that I hate maybe you
can create that within the confines
confines of your normal job or maybe you
can do it in the hours outside of your
normal job and it's gonna bring some
additional fulfillment to your life and
by the way nobody is supposed to do
anything you weren't born to be an
astronaut or an actor or a nurse or a
doctor or a chiropractor or a studio
engineer you you can do you can
cultivate virtually anything into a
passion yeah it's like we were born to
choose our path yes we weren't born into
a path and ultimately if you still can't
figure out like I don't know what I want
to create then here's what I'll say help
people solve problems eventually the
money will follow and don't start with
the money how am I going to make
that yourself how am I gonna help people
solve problems you're that barista at
Starbucks their problem is they need
some caffeine right now what's the best
way to get them that caffeine is it just
to be transactional and say may I take
your order and then and being monotone
and and blunt and borderline rude no
it's to create the best experience
possible so that you feel good about it
they feel good about it and it's
infectious with the the people around
you Emily I'd love to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains Ryan
and I went on this five-year journey
from these suit-and-tie corporate guys
to becoming minimalists and in that book
we sort of outlined the the planning
that we went through the the the
experience of walking away from one
thing I'm walking toward something that
we were passionate about so Sean if you
could reach out to her and send her the
audiobook version of that if you like
our podcast you'll definitely like the
audiobook version or if you prefer the
book book or the e-book we'll be happy
to send those to you as well our next
question is from Josh in London Ontario
Canada
I have no problem when it comes to
minimalizing my material things where I
have a problem and where I see a lot of
my money going is the what I consider
true consumables like fast food and
treats and snacks and soda pop and you
know that sort of thing and I'm really
having a tough time I guess minimalizing
that aspect of my spending and that
aspect of my life you guys have any
advice for minimalizing what I call I
guess a true consumable Josh I am Josh
and Josh yes I am I don't know what true
consumable I don't know what the
difference between true consumable and
consumable is and Josh's question he
write it sounds to me like what he's
saying is is uh he has consumables you
know that are good to eat but then these
true consumables which are really just
on an unhealthy diet yes what it sounds
like so we can continue to use the term
true consumable I still don't maybe he
means physical consumable so like okay
because you can consume music which is
digital
I can consume that broccoli and chicken
right alright so maybe he just means
physical consumable so yeah yeah but but
he's also talking about these like
treats basically yeah an axe and other
things and the thing that I'll say to
Josh in Ontario Ontario is treats are no
longer treats when they become routine
you know if you're having the Mountain
Dew and Twinkies every day then that's
just a bad diet you're not treating
yourself no you I mean you are treating
yourself poorly yeah you [ __ ] yourself
to diabetes well here's the thing so
when I look at consumables or let's just
say physical goods in my life
you often hear Ryan and I talk about the
need like one list and if I were to
rewrite that one today I would just I
move my things into three different
categories any any object that I own any
object that I possess falls into one of
three categories either essential
non-essential or junk and I think we lie
to ourselves about most
things we can we can justify virtually
anything and we we say most of our junk
is adding value to our lives we say most
of our non essentials are essential and
of course most of our essentials are so
precious we dare not even question them
mm-hmm but here's here's the truth with
the things in my life the essentials are
things that I truly need I need clothes
but it doesn't matter which clothes I
have if this shirt were to rip today I
have another shirt or I think I can
obtain another shirt I'm not going to be
tied to it with respect to
sentimentality or or nostalgia I think
nostalgia can be dangerous right but I
do need clothes I need a roof over my
head and then there are very few things
that I truly need in my life but there
are some absolute essentials this is a
really important exercise especially if
you have any kind of debt and you're
trying to get out of debt what are the
bare minimum essentials what am i
spinning mom well I have to spend my
money on beyond that are non essentials
but those are the things that add value
to your life
I bought a couch a few weeks ago we
talked about that on episode I think 119
the decorations episode and that adds
value to my life it is a non-essential I
don't have to have a couch but it does
add value to my life I could afford it
and it adds value to my life it doesn't
get in the way of anything either and I
have other well I other things that add
value to my life they're non-essential
and I have to be honest about that and I
have to be willing to let go of them if
they stop adding value to my life the
third area is the junk the things that
we think we need the things that we say
add value to my life when I say add
value does a serve a purpose or does it
bring me joy and if I'm honest with
myself a lot of the things I had before
they just got in the way and if
something is getting in the way then it
is just junk and if you're worrying
about it like Josh is with this stuff
literally we're talking about junk food
well by definition junk food is junk you
don't need it is in the way it's not
only non-essential it is junk it is a
consumable it's certainly not a true
consumable because there is not a bit of
truth in it that's the truth man preach
no you know Josh it's I'm speaking to
Josh in London here Josh you you have to
you got to come up with some better
habits for me I found replacements for
those those junk that junk food that I
really enjoyed so as I've mentioned on
this podcast before about my my
diagnosis where I was you know
borderline type 2 diabetes I had to stop
you know eating ice cream and I freaking
love ice cream
like I haven't that I take about I was
in so haven't had ice cream and you know
probably five or six months but I've had
like three bites of ice cream compared
to when I was eating it you know a nice
big scoop or two scoops once or twice a
week but I'll tell you what I do eat a
lot of now 100% dark chocolate yeah like
Trader Joe's has this I wish I had the
brand so if Sean could put it in the
notes I'll figure it out and maybe send
it to him is that coconut recipe okay
yeah yeah it's got like these so it's
like a Josh and I Milburn and I we were
comparing it to the Nestle Crunch bar
yeah which was like my Ryan I were fat
kids back really the crunch bars were by
far my favorite and this Trader Joe's
it's like a healthy Nestle Crunch Bart
now it's not nearly as sugary it you
know doesn't give me that that endorphin
rush when when I eat it like a Nestle
Crunch bar would but after I have cut
out all that all the the junk food in my
life and and now like that is what I
have like it's it's my new favorite so
you know now I got a couple bars of that
at home and like just talking about it
I'm like you know my mouth is watering a
little bit I want to have a couple
squares and there's only like five grams
of sugar in the entire bar like it's not
it's it's a very very low sugar thing in
fact at Trader Joe's cuz I'll buy I
bought like five or six bars of it
uh-huh
the cashier was like oh let me guess
this is your favorite choc and I'm like
yep this is my favorite chocolate she
was like I can't stand it like I you
know they came in here and they gave us
out samples and it's just way too bitter
for me and and I'm like you know what it
was really bitter for me too until that
until I kept only that in my life and I
cut out all the other crap your body
starts to appreciate different things so
Josh it just doesn't mean Josh in London
it doesn't mean that you have to you
know cut out every single bad thing in
your diet but I would encourage you too
start replacing some things some junk
foods with healthy food yeah what what
are the alternatives is basically what
you're saying yeah start with fast food
I would say instead of instead of just
getting rid of the thing is what is the
alternative to the thing that way you
don't have to say no no no no no you're
still saying yes but you're saying yes
to the better option and sometimes like
with physical goods for me it means I'm
saying yes to more space and and I'm
saying yes to less clutter and yes to
that feeling of like oh this this feels
like home to me why would I want to ruin
that feeling yeah because nothing ever
tastes as good as being healthy feels
that's the truth Josh I would tell you
to start with with fast food eating fast
food is not very intentional fast food
is a very impulsive it's it's it is when
we have time constraints when we're
really hungry whatever it is we will
fall on the crutch of fast food I used
to always do it I would challenge you to
be more intentional with your meals if
you have to eat out that's okay there
are places that you can find where
you're not gonna have to eat you know
big juicy cheeseburger and large fry and
a super-sized coke you could totally go
somewhere else and find and find a good
substitute cooking for yourself packing
meals I used to do that especially when
oh you and I were vegan for a year like
I would have to pack meals cuz I quickly
found out eating healthy especially
eating vegan wasn't too easy in in in
Ohio and Cincinnati Ohio
so I had to pack a lot of my meals but
again Josh once you start to instill
these habits into your life man like
you're really really gonna feel good
about it and you're not even gonna miss
the junk food I cannot believe how how
much I don't miss any of the junk food
like what the ice cream for example the
three bites that I've had all three
bites very anticlimactic it's like I'm
funny man looking at it
mariah is having some she doesn't eat
ice cream too often either maybe a
little bit more than me sorry to throw
you under the bus there Mariah but I'll
be you know watching her like eat a
scoop of ice cream or something and it
looks good and my brain saying man
that's
good and I'm like oh yeah let me get a
bite of that and then I take a bite and
I'm like because I have gone so you know
so long without it yeah they're like now
I'm just like man I can't remember a
time now I'm sure there are gonna be an
example somewhere that's gonna disprove
this but I can't remember a time where
I'm like I'm really glad I ate those
tortilla chips yesterday it's I wish I
would have eaten more of those tortilla
chips in fact okay so okay listen let's
say maybe it happens point 1 percent of
the time but yeah dude when when we
would sit there and Gorge ourselves with
ice cream and hamburgers and all the
unhealthy foods no one feels good after
that now no one says oh you know what I
feel so good I'm gonna go run a mile or
I'm gonna go work on my passion project
like usually after I eat that crap it
makes me tired yeah
makes me feel bloated yeah there's no
there's no good outcome the only the
only good thing about eating that stuff
is the ephemerality it's in the moment
and getting those fast burning carbs
into your body and your body's like yeah
thanks but then like as soon as it
starts to digest them it your body's
like oh wait maybe not thanks yeah yeah
it's like screw you right
all right well Josh I'd love to send you
a copy of our book essential it's an
essay collection there's a hundred and
fifty essays in essential and there's 12
different chapters in there about twelve
different well different twelve
different topics on intentional living
one of those chapters is about stuff and
how we can be more intentional about the
stuff that we get rid of and also the
stuff that we bring into our lives so
Josh I think you'll find a and oh
there's some really practical tips in
there as well so it's not just
pontificating there's some some good
tips I think of fun valuing Sean if he
can give him the audiobook or the e-book
or the book book whatever he wants we
would appreciate that we'd love to hear
what you have to say so if you have a
comment or tip about intentionality
including advice for any of our callers
today then leave us voicemail four zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm right
there from your phone where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
also stay tuned to the end of this
episode will air your comments and tips
the end of this episode Ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it is
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media dude
was in a was at assembly in high school
and we had like a speaker I don't know
if you remember this or not he was just
there basically talking about like hey
kid here's how to here's how to you know
live a live a good life actually kind of
did what I want to do man
but but at the very end of it he was
like I don't want to make it rain
do you I don't even remember this not
and he had everyone like start to like
snap and then like everyone like rub
their hands together and then like
everyone clap and it's totally with the
whole an entire crowd it sounded like a
storm was coming and I was gonna attempt
that on this transition but uh I I don't
I don't know - I don't think it's gonna
work we're just everyone in the audience
everyone listen if you start shopping
and clapping right now we'll all be good
alright anyway we're on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists as our handle over there on
all three of those during the lightning
rounds where Ryan and I each do our best
to answer every question which is too
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our answers on on
social media if you'd like and also you
can find all of our quotes in one place
now thanks to our good friend Jessica
Lynn Williams over at minimal Maxim's
com alright our first question is from
Sabrina setting intentions is the easy
part how do you remind yourself to
recall those intentions during
day-to-day life well here's my pithy
answer for you Sabrina and then we could
talk about it knowing the why behind the
what makes the how more manageable so
let's just talk about that for a second
intention is only the what right you
also need to know the why and the how
why am I doing this it meaning whether
what's the purpose of what I'm about to
do and then then the the the what is or
the how is what what do I hope to
accomplish here right I'm sorry that
that's the what and how is how will I
get there right so why am i doing this
what's the purpose the what is what do I
hope to accomplish and then how will I
get there
also if you
do less you can be more right you know
it's our good friend Courtney Carver has
a website called be more with less and
and I think that also applies to our
busy world or the busy work that we're
involved in every day it's like more and
more and more and more filling my
calendar just for the sake of filling
the calendar that's not prioritizing
it's just being busy but if you do less
you can actually be more productive my
answer to you Sabrina is this intentions
are different from intentionality
setting intentions without committing to
action well it's like buying a
ThighMaster just so you can store it in
your closet what a great analogy so
Sabrina here's what I'm saying is you do
know how to remind yourself throughout
your day-to-day life
I mean I can think of five things just
off the top of my head I could have a
friend call me and remind me I could set
a reminder of my calendar I could set a
task reminder on my phone I could sign
up for the app that reminds me I'm gonna
die every single day I could take you
know five minutes every single day and
meditate I mean there are a million
things that you can do but you Sabrina
have to decide what it is that's gonna
work for you so yes setting intentions
is important but you have to take action
every single day to continue to continue
those intentions to continue being
intentional in your life so Sabrina you
know what to do you just got to do it do
you don't have to do everything at once
maybe you start maybe maybe you start
meditating for five minutes a day during
lunch just start there but but but you
do have to choose what things that
you're going to bring in your life what
actions you need to take - to constantly
remind yourself to be intentional but
more importantly I think it's not about
just being intentional as much as it is
building those really really good habits
in your life Sabrina all right our next
question is from Jay from Indonesia many
people have a habit in which they must
always drop their two cents on other
people's lives based on their utmost
good intentions when actually it's
distressing to others maintaining
politeness when you're upset is quite
hard to do any tips so here's my pithy
answer for you Jay good intentions often
lack in 10
Cinelli so it's echoing sort of Orion
said in the last answer intentions are
different from intentionality right so
so what Jay's talking about here and in
this example is the good intentions are
actually an excuse for bad behavior
people were saying I have good
intentions when I'm [ __ ] all over
you that's not yeah I don't care how
good your intention is if you are doing
harm if you're doing something bad then
that's just bad and they aren't acting
with intention at all and so I just
realized like good intentions it's like
like people justify it as a good excuse
to do a bad thing exactly that's that is
that's horrible you got a short answer
for us Ryan I do I do
confidence is key when navigating
through people's judgments an
intentional life is a path to confidence
so here's what I'm saying Jay if you're
living up to your values and beliefs if
you are living an intentional life if
you can look in the mirror and say that
you are doing the best job that you can
then Jay it's gonna be really really
easy to ignore those folks who are
giving you their two cents on what to do
with your life yeah and sometimes you
can say you know I don't I don't need
the your two cents regardless of what
your intentions are it's not helpful
yeah it's okay to say something isn't
helpful it absolutely is it no I'll tell
you - a lot of the times like when
people give me their two cents I'll just
you know I'll say hey thanks for your
thanks for your opinion right and I will
you know take it into consideration yeah
whether I do or don't ya probably don't
and and you can be that's a nice way to
be dismissive and move on yes
hey thanks thanks for your opinion
thanks for thoughts that's a great
thought Thanks yeah yeah all right one
more question here is from Bradford Gant
Bradford says I would be interested in
an exploration of the relationship
between acting with intent and being
motivated by or expecting certain
outcomes so if you want to hear our
answers to that question you can listen
to this week's PostScript episode over
at the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters that's why it's a private
podcast Ryan you know we just we just
fell our fifth
private podcast episode last yeah it's
been 50 already 50 so if you're missing
out if you're not a patreon subscriber
there are 50 additional private podcast
episodes is it a little short no they're
like these these miniature episodes
quite often many of them are 8 to 20
minutes long and we we dive deep we let
our hair down and and there's just a few
thousand people over there so we we can
get a bit more aggressive with our
answer so if you want to support our
show and keep this podcast 100 percent
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly post grip
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask the
minimalist anything episodes unreleased
recordings from our live events and the
entire back catalogue of past private
episodes once you become a supporter
you'll also receive a personal link to
our private podcast feed so that it
plays right there and whatever podcast
app you're using to listen to this
podcast in right now and as a patreon
supporter you also receive access to our
monthly live stream videos as well as
first access to tickets to all of our
live events including the simply
southern tour and so you get those
tickets though the best seats in the
house before they're available to the
general public you can find all the
details and all the good stuff over at
the minimalists comm slash support and
here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode
I bring this up because you don't need
to know anything about basketball to
realize that he he won
way more than anyone else but you know
what he never focused on the score of
the game mmm
he told us guys that you know you know
if you won the game regardless of what
the outcome is mm-hmm so what I would
say is recall what your expectation is
if your expectation is to get more
points than the other team then you're
going to be disappointed if you don't do
that but if you go out there and give it
your all and you lose by one point you
can look yourself in the mirror and say
I gave it my all the opposite is also
true maybe you beat an inferior team and
you won by a point we didn't give it
your all did you really win all right
we're back if you want to hear that full
conversation you become a patreon
supporter over at the minimalists com
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where Ryan
and I both talk about something that has
added value to our lives recently I've
got a few things here Ryan so let's see
I got a new phone recently and it's not
the phone that's adding value but
something I've done with it that is
adding value tomorrow my life so I got a
new phone because we're doing some more
video creations and I'm gonna start
something called living room
conversations next month on YouTube I'm
just gonna answer a question today from
folks and maybe I can coerce you and
they're coming over to my living room
and do questions with me we'll have a
guest star Ryan Nicodemus on the living
room conversations but I'm trying to use
YouTube a little bit more for video
creation so I'm one that was better for
that but there's one thing I'm doing on
my phone now you know they're really
annoying clicking noise and people like
you see like centenarians like clicking
their phones I click click click click
click click click click it sounds like
you can turn on the like the hepatech
feedback not the haptic feedback but the
they'll just the actual audible clicking
of the keys well the I think the
clicking is iPhones version of peptic
feedback because you got both actually
if there are they allowed wait I thought
haptic feedback was like I'm getting
kind of weeds here but I thought it was
Oh
it was proprietary - yes I understand
that are you getting hectic feedback
though you can turn peptic feedback
online I don't have it on I didn't
realize you could on I hear that yes I
got you
I turned that on yeah and the reason I
turned it on is because it's annoying to
other people now it's not my intention
to annoy others it's my intention to be
more intentional with my phone mhm and
so I know that I have been practicing
you know hey if I have to take text
message I've talked about this in
previous podcast I'll walk outside and
say hey excuse me for a second why take
this message but this allows me even
around strangers to be to realize like
oh you're being that annoying person
with your keys all loud and so you
probably don't need to be texting right
it's a reminder to me that I probably
don't need to be doing this right now
so that's one thing that's been adding
value to my life also I the apartment
building I live in has a just really
small gym downstairs with a pull-up bar
down there so I didn't buy a pull-up bar
for the apartment I'm in right now and I
missed it and I realized like I can't
live this is something that truly adds
died in my life this is borderline
essential for me
I need a pull-up bar in the place that I
live I need it in my bedroom
because every time I walk under it I
like to do six quick pull-ups and you
can't really do they get to go down the
gym every time it just doesn't work
right mm-hmm
I've been watching the the NBA playoffs
and so every time there's a commercial
break I go and do 10 pull-ups and 35
push-ups and a bunch of squats by the
end of the basketball game I am
exhausted
because they have so many dislike
commercials like you've been playing
ball of them I exactly I'm right there
with LeBron James basically but I they
still in it oh yeah yeah no way oh yeah
well I'm not going to the finals I think
what's that what's that so is it still
sell ticking Cleveland yeah Celtics in
Cleveland
it's 3 to 2 as of this recording
although by the time this comes out who
knows what will happen so three to two
favored by the Celtics right now yeah
Celtics won last night okay
yeah yeah so there they won in Boston
but anyway um yeah I've found that like
it's a cuz I don't want to be a couch
potato I'm just gonna watch the game
right now so I'll turn the game on as
soon as it hits commercial even if I
don't want to I I'm up I'm doing the
pull-ups it's it's the price of
admission for me watching the TV and so
pull-up bar I'll put a link to the
particular pull-up bar I use it's really
great is it the one that drills in yeah
yeah you have to drill I'll do it to
drill it in yeah but it's it's really
simple if I can install it than anyone
with two arms can install it I support
that statement I will put a link to the
the one that I use in the show notes
it's it's a really good pull-up bar and
it stays there and it supports it
supports my weight
oh and one album that I've been just
really diggin a lot of singer-songwriter
stuff recently and there was a gal named
Phoebe Bridgers I recommended a song
from her she did with Noah Gunderson a
few weeks ago that video but her album
is called stranger in the Alps and it is
definitely one of my three favorite
albums of the entire year and she has a
song attack Sean if we could end this
episode with her song it's called smoke
signals
it's the the first track on her new
album it is just gorgeous and it reminds
me so much of Los Angeles it's awesome
yeah check it out man so those are my
three added values turning on the
keyboard sounds pull-up bar and working
out there and commercial breaks
obviously and then TV Bridgers album I I
recommended this yesterday on on the
patreon live stream that we did I'm
gonna recommend in here too so I
downloaded the news app it's called the
good news app I love this idea man and
it literally so there is there is a
company good Inc yeah and we know max
yeah I know I love those guys and I
think that this news app it truly I'm
not trying to put good ink down because
I do love them but it does it does sway
one way or the other like there are when
you when I when I when I go to that
website there are some
there are some partisan issues
essentially gotcha so with the good news
app this is truly a bipartisan app yeah
it is nonpartisan home or nonpartisan
the admin sorry um but but here's the
thing is like it is a little bit
christiany uh-huh
and I mean I'm not a Christian I
wouldn't like claim to actually if I had
to pick a religion maybe that's what I
would be but like my point is is like
I'm not a religious guy yeah
so but it doesn't bother me III can you
know I can still take the good from it
sure some people they like stay clear
from that so the good news app is
something that you probably wouldn't
want to do then cuz like I said it does
lean a bit towards the Christian you
side of things but it truly is every
time you go to to the app you have good
news feel good stories I'm just reading
this morning about how Boeing just sold
their first 100 plane electric planes so
like wow they are starting to build
planes that run on electricity there's
no political BS on this news app there
is there is no there's no judgments of
any kind on this app it is not divisive
it is not exclusive it is very inclusive
it's the opposite of all of the news yes
exactly it's the only it is truly the
only there might be some other ones out
there and if you do know of anyone
listening this if you know some other
good news apps that are similar or you
know the same as what I'm talking about
hit me up on Twitter or you can call in
and leave a voicemail for the four up
for a tip for Josh and I but right now
it's the only one I've been able to find
because I do love reading the news I
love staying informed but most news
outlets right now well you know you
could pray without looking at the news
for the past two weeks or two months you
could probably guess all the bullcrap
that's in the news right now that you
cannot get past well you can get past it
if you if you use this app I'm gonna
feel a whole lot better by ingesting
consuming with that which is good yes
absolutely
all right let's move on to right here
right now so we talked about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
we're going to be hiring a filmmaker
soon because we're starting to do a
video version of the podcast I'm
pointing at the camera right now Ryan we
got our first camera in
Matt helped us set it up yesterday it's
not on right now I'm thinking maybe we
try to record next week if we can
coercion into recording until we have a
a filmmaker to come in so in June
probably on June 10th I think we're
gonna put up some details are gonna be
looking for a filmmaker and so we're
looking for some reels from folks who
are interested in doing that kind of
thing
with all the details up at the
minimalists comm speaking of the
minimalists comm we've got a bunch of
good stuff going on a bunch of new
writings I've been writing like a madman
not just for the website but there are a
few things that have made it onto the
website this is an essay I wrote
recently called accessories now
accessories is spelled with an e e
x c ESS I see what you did there
accessories in the western world money
may serve as a loose marker of
confidence one's ability to provide for
a family save for retirement and stay
out of debt are all signs of his or her
proficiency ostentatious displays of
material wealth however are evidence of
incompetence
not unlike peacocks humans feel the need
to signal their supposed prosperity to
attract others and even when we don't
have the means the modern world makes it
easy for us to flex our consumerist
muscles by way of 0% financing luxury
rentals and other modes of consumer
fakery even nine year olds are flaunting
their excess these days I put a little
link to the little toy video so I have
you are you are you familiar with little
Tay I know about little days because
just like you you got a depressed look
on you yes that's where the video would
coming into play the only reason I know
about little taste cuz I saw something
come across Twitter or something where
it was the outtakes of little day and
her brother just closed his courses her
the whole time so like she's actually a
pretty normal kid yeah he's I'm sure
that like she's like [ __ ] it's like
she's an actress it's what she sure I
hope I hope she's like so good that
she's just like on Saturday Night Live
one day and yeah
all fakery but it is it's sad it's
saddening well dude this is this is a
sign dude of Lake of where our society
is heading yeah I'm the youngest flexor
of the century dude you're like come on
that that is that's a goes back to this
line right ostentatious displays of
material wealth however our evidence of
incompetence and a previous episode you
and I talked about the the chrome-plated
Bentley we saw to me that isn't a sign
of I mean wealth is is great if you can
do some really great things with it
right and so yeah go ahead well it's
just a little tame for those of you out
there listening this you like what the
hell are these guys talking about
she's a she's a she's a kid who just
basically I'm rich and I got everything
and you all are suckers and I mean it's
like this look at me
yeah I'm rich - look how young I am I'm
better than you I'm better than all of
you and somehow people love being told
that they're not as good as little Tay I
don't know what it is about that man but
to me I think it's watching a train
wreck it is
yeah maybe watching a train wreck but
it's it's unfortunate though the like
this is what we focus on man like this
is what this is what I don't want to say
drives us but it's certainly it
certainly is something that that drives
people the I'm better than you I have
more money than you
I have better status than you and anyone
honestly who has that attitude man like
but like we were talking about in the
past episode that's insecurity coming
out you are insecure about your status
in society yeah that is that is it's
it's just unfortunate that I don't know
man that like people like a little day
can be popular and we're like wow Vicky
or any of the other ones who while Vicky
she's just another gal who's like little
takes that she's older yeah same exact
thing Coke and Pepsi yeah it's
unbelievable yeah so back to the the
second half of this this really sighs
short essay here when you step back
though you realize how silly this is
look at my chrome plate of rims my logo
plated handbag my oversized house with
more toilets than people don't I look
relevant but of course
excess isn't a symptom of relevancy it
isn't even a demonstration of happiness
or significance or well-being in fact
the opposite is usually true our excess
or Rees merely hide our discontent while
showcasing our insecurities yeah at the
same time absolutely so if you want to
read that essay or there's several other
new ones there head on over to the
minimalists com you can also subscribe
to our email there I just thought in
your email address the top you'll get
all the show notes that we publish for
the podcast any new writings also any
new tour announcements if we decide to
go on tour in your area you'll be the
first to to know about that what else we
got going on here oh the simply southern
tour we already talked about that
Kentucky Tennessee Alabama the public
sale is those go on sale to the public
on June 8th and and then if your patreon
supporter will you'll be I'll have
access on June 6th
I mentioned living room conversations so
every day in June on YouTube I'm gonna
answer one question I don't know how
long it'll be it could be a minute it
could be five minutes could be 10
minutes I'm also gonna do a new home
tour on YouTube so June will be a good
month on YouTube I'll try to drag Ryan
over as many times as I can to answer
some some questions we'll just do one
question today make it brief make it
tailored for the American attention span
I guess the the Western or worldwide
attention span the internet attention
span these days I just saw it was like a
meme or something that said directions
on how to watch TV in 2018 first turn on
Netflix second be overwhelmed by all the
choices third pick a show or series
you've seen a million times for push
play five surf on your telephone for two
hours that's about right so while you're
on your phone for two hours maybe you'll
find something useful on our YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the minimalist
also I'm teaching a writing class in
June twice a year I do a writing
workshop it's a two-hour online writing
workshop it's a distilled down version
of the four-week class I teach over at
how to write better org and this 2-hour
workshop but basically it stands
on its own if you want some better
direction on improving your writing
habit also learning about composition
editing and publishing that's who our
workshop is June 24th this year you can
find the details too that it's limited
the 300 seats I've said seats and quotes
here because it's it's an online
workshop durable seats yes the
minimalists comm slash workshop if you
want to learn how to write more clearly
and improve your writing whether it's
business emails or blogging or you want
to write your first book I've got some
tips that'll help you out video podcast
coming soon youtube.com slash the
minimalist which may be try that next
week for next week's episode and I think
that's all I got Ryan you got anything
else yeah man I got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
here you go hi my name is Jess and I
have gone from being a Shopaholic to a
minimalist and it has completely changed
my life I just wanted to kind of share
with you a more effective form of using
the one in one out rule that has worked
for me so well that I've never even had
to make a swap so with the one in one
out rule one really good example is the
first step to that being effective is to
declutter honestly you know when you get
rid of your stuff be honest with
yourself like for example for me like my
jewelry collection I had so much jewelry
but I only wore like five things so it
took like three to four times and I
finally declared everything and I just
have one necklace I have one ring and
then a couple pair of earrings and
that's it you know so if I see this
necklace in the store and I'm just like
oh I really want that necklace instead
of thinking well I'll just buy it and
get rid of a pair of socks it doesn't
work that way if you if you buy a
necklace you have to get rid of a
necklace you have to get rid of a like
item and the reason why that works so
well for me is because I have reduced my
clutter so much that I only own one
necklace and I love it so much it's so
special to me there's no way I would buy
another necklace and replace it so it's
just it's really worked for me hi my
name is Elaine
and I'm from the Seattle area I wanted
to leave a comment on the role of
minimalism and healing that just really
spoke to me because about a year ago I
started going to counseling sessions to
work through some unresolved childhood
trauma that I had had that I had
experienced and you know I came across
minimalism at about the same time
without even really trying it just sort
of seemed natural to pair decluttering
with my home and my my surroundings
with kind of the the unpacking I was
doing in my mind so as I worked through
all of this trauma and repressed
feelings and and everything I became
lighter and that really paired well with
with all of the stuff I was getting rid
of as well so you know the more stuff I
got rid of just the more kind of whole
and and open and and you know I I just I
felt like I had more time and space for
the healing kind of like what what
Joshua said about giving yourself the
space to heal so yeah I can't really
imagine my my psychological healing
without the minimalism attached to it
because to me it's kind of they're very
deeply intertwined hi Josh and Ryan this
is Mike from st. Louis Missouri I'd like
to share an observation that I made at
my place of employment the entrance to
the building has a handicap accessible
door that opens with the push of a
button I often see able-bodied people
utilizing this feature rather than
opening the door with their hands
because they are carrying too much stuff
with them such as up to three bags and a
cup in their hand so basically they are
rendering themselves incapable of
opening a door without assistance to me
this is a great illustration of how
things can weigh people down to contrast
this a few months ago I took a week-long
vacation and was able to bring
everything I needed
in a single backpack and this was a
liberating experience so one bag for a
week versus three bags for a single day
is a difference worth considering
next time you go somewhere alright y'all
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also email a
voice memo right from your phone to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
enjoy this song from phoebe Bridgers
it's called smoke signals you sure you
want me to just sing it I can alright
well let her sing it alright do it
hey if your listen to this on YouTube
well we can't put Phoebe Bridgers music
on YouTube it's already there we'll put
a link to it in the show notes check out
her song smoke signals you can also
listen to her album stranger in the Alps
I think you'll really enjoy it
and minimalists